[MUSIC PLAYING]
MATT LEONARD: Good
morning, everybody.
Thanks for joining us
here at Google Next.
My name is Matt Leonard.
I'm a product manager in the
Google Cloud billing platform.
Before joining Google Cloud and
joining the billing team here,
I actually worked in
billing at Azure and AWS,
so someone who you'd call
a self-inflicted billing
Cloud expert, unfortunately.
Today, I want to talk
about financial governance
for managing your
Cloud business.
So I think most of us
here in the IT industry
can agree that Cloud has
disrupted the way that we
manage our business and how we
go about procuring and managing
infrastructure.
We're focusing on expanding.
It's changed the way that
we buy our infrastructure.
In a traditional model, it's
a very centralized processes.
It's controlled.
It's predictable.
Everything is run
through a budget cycle.
We have financial controls,
checks and balances,
to ensure that spending
doesn't get out of control.
The Cloud's disrupted that.
Anyone in your
company with access
can now spin up instances that
you don't have any visibility
to, and you end up
reacting to cost,
rather than planning for it.
This IT expanding, it's moved
from a CapEx expense, which
is predictable over a
long period of time,
to an OpEx expense, which is
coming out on a monthly basis,
and you're managing and
trying to control that spend.
So to play on this
metaphor, you wouldn't
build a ship that's
full of holes,
and you don't want to
approach your Cloud
billing in the same way.
You need a plan.
You need a strategy for
your financial governance.
Lack of financial
governance in the Cloud
can be kind of
shocking if it happens
to you as an organization.
I have a couple of examples that
I wanted to share of incidents
that I've been involved
with in my years of working
in cloud billing.
We had a customer recently
that was doing a load and scale
test.
They spun up 9,000 instances,
ran their load test.
A few days later, they realized
they hadn't switched up
the environment.
Whoops.
It was an expensive
problem have.
I also worked with
an ISP at one point.
They were doing a
solution that they
wanted to run on multi-cloud.
So they used
clarification on AWS
and they spun up
their templates.
And the way the
CloudFormation works
is when you do a deployment
and that deployment fails,
CloudFormation is stateful, and
it rolls back the resources.
They then went over
to Azure, and they
started using our templates.
And they're launching
instances, and off they go.
Well, ARM is not stateful.
It doesn't rollback instances
in a failed deployment.
This customer may end up with
a $350,000 bill for Azure
because they weren't
watching their spend.
But this doesn't
have to be a reality.
Your reality can be much more
controlled and predictable.
We had another customer
recently that, basically--
application, engineer
checked in some code.
Their normal run rate
for the storage expenses
on this application
was about 0.04%
of their application's
cost profile.
It went to 45% over night.
Luckily, they were
monitoring this.
They had controls in place.
They saw the change in
the application profile,
were able to rollback that
code, and control their expense.
So that's what we're
here today to talk about,
what tools do we have in
the Google Cloud toolkit
that are going to help you
with your financial-governance
strategy.
And then we have Lucas
here from the Broad who
is going to talk about
how they managed it
at scale for the business.
So some of the quick questions
you need to ask yourself,
when you think about your
financial-governance strategy,
is how is my cost organized?
If you attended the
session earlier,
James Byers did a
session called--
and sorry, I'm just going to
make sure I get it right here--
Managing Costs in GCP, How
to Structure Your Resources.
And this laid out some
of the best practices.
And so if you weren't
able to attend that,
I'd suggest that
you catch it online.
But it talks about some of
the different mechanisms
that you have in Google
Cloud to organize your cost.
So we have folders.
We have projects,
and we have labels.
And those are
different mechanisms
by which you can
organize your costs,
either in a structured
hierarchy or in a crosscutting
or cross-project way.
But it's pretty
important, because that's
what you're going to bind
all your financial-governance
policy to, how you
organize costs.
And you're probably not
going to want to look
at it at a single level.
You're going to want to look at
it by project, which probably
represents a team, or an
application, or an environment.
But you might want to also
look at it by organization.
I have a department.
I want to see how much
this department is
costing at totality.
So I want to monitor
at multiple levels.
Second, what is my budget?
This is really important.
How much do I actually
expect to spend?
So we're going to look at,
like, where have I been?
How much did it
cost me in the past?
Where is it going in the future?
How is my cost projected
at the current run rate?
And then what if--
what if we changed
the characteristics
of this application, changed
the profile of the machines
that we're using?
What if we had a 4x increase
in the amount of traffic
that's going to
hit this platform?
We want to play out
some of these scenarios
so that we can understand
what is my budget,
and how am I going
to manage that?
And then lastly, what
is the budget impact?
This is kind of an
interesting one.
What would you want to do
when you get to your budget?
The most passive
form of impact is
I'm going to just
notify some people.
I'm going to let you know
that something is happening
that you weren't expecting.
But it can be much,
much more intrusive.
I hear customers a lot
who talk about capping.
I want to cap.
Actually, I'm fine if you
delete all my resources,
you blow away all my storage,
and you make this never exist,
because I don't want
to pay another penny.
And Lucas will talk about
some of those use cases
himself, actually,
because it's something
that you hear in
dev-test environments,
in students, where they actually
can't pay another penny.
And so they need
to stop that cost.
More than likely, you
probably have a strategy
somewhere in between.
So-- oops.
Did I skip a slide?
No, I did not.
So our goal here
at Google Cloud is
to give you a toolkit, because
there is no one size fits all.
What you run in your
production environment
may be very, very
different to what
you want to put in a
sandbox environment
so that people can play
around with the Cloud.
So we want to give you
lots of different options.
So today, we're going to talk
about a few different tools
in the toolkit.
We're going to talk
about promotions.
We are going to
talk about quota,
and we're going to talk
about budget, and how you
can use those in your business.
And then Lucas is going to give
you some real-life examples.
This is permissions.
I'm just going explain this
diagram for a little bit,
because I'm being told that
it's a little bit distracting
with the way it keeps spinning.
Essentially, you want to operate
in an environment of least
privilege.
So you can see here
in this diagram
that, effectively, a user is
allowed to access resources
and launch them, unless
permission denies it.
The way that you
use least privilege
is going to differ, again,
between your production
environment and the
sandbox environment.
In your production
environment, you
might have a very
strict permissions
model, where only a few users
can access and launch resources
in that production environment.
But you may have
somewhat of a looser
financial-governance
model, where you don't
want to terminate resources.
You don't want to cap spending.
You just want to be notified.
It's a lot more passive.
Whereas in your
sandbox environment,
you might want a very strict
financial-governance policy
that says, I want to
terminate these resources when
my cost gets to foo,
or you can only launch
so many different instances.
But you may have a very
loose permissions model.
Anybody can spend up one of
these non-production accounts,
as long as it's
financially gallant.
Quota.
Quota basically enables you to
build a virtual data center.
It basically sets the
maximum concurrent resources
that you can operate.
Now, today, the way that Quota
operates is essentially by SKU.
And so an example of that
is the number of cores
that you can launch for compute.
So if you set a Quota control
that says, I have 100 cores.
That's like a physical data
center where you can only
put so many VMs into rack, and
you can only put so many racks
into a physical-data center.
And so you've actually
controlled the maximum amount
of resources that a
user can spend up,
and so therefore, you've
controlled the cost.
It's not going to be
more than 100 bitcoin,
or whatever 100
VMs will cost you,
because you've maximized the
amount that they can spend.
Now, they might not
spend 100 cores,
but they can spend
up to 100 cores.
Now, if it's a
dev-test environment,
and somebody is just playing
around with an environment,
you might want to set that
to 3, for example, which
is a very low
number and you know
that you're not going to
have a large cost spend-out.
So this is what a Quota
environment looks like right
now.
There's lots of
interesting things
that will be coming
down the track here
that we can talk about in a Q&A
session, if you're interested.
But basically, that
Quota enables you
to throttle your total spend.
But you have to think about what
that does to your environment.
If it's a production
environment,
is it OK for you to have that
degradation of performance.
If you hit the 100 cores,
things are going to slow down.
Or if you're in
BigQuery, and you
have a maximum amount of
slots, Query is going to sit.
And they're going wait, waiting
for a slot to open up to run.
And so quotas great but
you have to think about how
that impacts your business.
Last weekend, we
talked about budgets.
Budgets enable you to normalize
usage across everything
that we have in Cloud.
Today, we have a lot of
SKUs, close to 100,000 SKUs--
if you want to look at in
the myriad detail across all
the different regions
and different products
and different ways that
you can spend things up.
And what budget allows
you to do is normalize it
into cost over time.
So it becomes very
simple, and you
can decide what you want to do
as you hit your budget limits.
Today in Google Cloud, we let
you monitor a monthly budget
per project or per
billing account.
So you can specify that.
And you can get a
simple notification
when you hit a preset threshold.
So you could say, I have
a 100 bitcoin to spend.
When I get to 50 bitcoin,
I want you to tell me,
because I want to
see how I'm trending.
You can also automate
budget actions.
We recently launched
a new feature called
programmatic notifications.
This essentially allows you to
build your own budget policy.
Now eventually, we
want to bring this over
to a function of the console.
But today, what that
allows you to do
is to specify a
Cloud Function, like,
a different set of actions.
And we provide some basic
reference architectures,
which will go into
in a bit more detail.
But you can do things like
you can forward your budget
notification to different
mediums, like Slack.
Or you can suspend resources.
We gave an example policy of how
to take a budget notification
and shut down all the
compute instances.
Or you can cap spending.
You can actually
pull a project out
of a billing which will farm out
a termination of all resources
in that billing account.
And so this is a
fairly powerful tool
with a fairly-simple
implementation.
I had a customer
recently told me
it took them about seven
minutes to set it up,
so fairly straightforward.
All right.
Without further ado, I'm
going to introduce Lucas
from the Broad, and he is
going to talk about how
they operate at scale.
LUKAS KARLSSON: Thank you, Matt.
Let's see here.
OK.
I'm Lukas Karlsson.
I work at the Broad Institute.
Am I going backwards here?
I've been with the Broad
for a little over 15 years.
I started exactly two weeks
after the Broad Institute
completed the Human
Genome Project in 2003.
And over the last
15 years, we've
sequenced something like 100,000
genomes, after that first one.
Started as a systems
administrator
and moved into a manager
of systems administrators.
And then I became a bit
of a software engineer,
writing web applications
and other automation tools.
And at some point, we needed
to create a DevOps group,
so I took two years or so
and created a DevOps group
at the Broad.
And now, I'm responsible
for our Cloud environment
and for the success
of our developers
in using that environment.
If you don't know
about the Broad,
we are a research
institute doing
bioinformatics and
biology-type stuff
in Cambridge, Massachusetts.
As I mentioned, we were one
of the major contributors
for the Human Genome Project.
We also have a bunch
of other things
that you might have heard of.
For example, something
recent that we've worked on
is the CRISPR patent
for editing of genomes.
And we're organized around
major research areas
and major production services.
So for example, we have a
group that's focusing entirely
on cancer research.
We have another group
that's focusing entirely
on psychiatric disease research,
like depression and bipolar.
And then the platforms
run like small businesses
within the Institute that
provide a production service.
So for example, the
genomics platform
provides services around
extraction of DNA,
storing DNA, sequencing
DNA, and analyzing DNA.
We're funded from a number
of different sources.
So for example, we
have dozens and dozens
of different government
grants for different projects
that we're working on.
And each of those
grants, obviously,
have certain constraints on
how much resources they grant.
We have lots of different
philanthropic gifts as well.
And today, actually,
philanthropy has changed
a little bit, so people
don't have a tendency as much
to just give money to places.
They do this
venture philanthropy
where they're investing in a
particular scientific outcome.
So we have a lot of
those kinds of gifts.
And then we have some
inventions like CRISPR
and some software licensing
and stuff that we do,
that brings in some
revenue as well.
Now, when we're talking
about the Cloud,
there's a bunch of things
that we're concerned about.
As I mentioned, because
so much of our research
is funded by
government grants, we
have to be very thoughtful
about how we use those funds.
It's public funds first.
And second, there is
a lot of constraints.
A given grant might only have
a certain amount of money
available to it over
a certain time period.
And then only a
portion of that grant
is what's going to be used
for the Cloud computing.
A lot of it might be
used for the sequencing
or other parts of the process.
And when we do overspend
on one of these grants,
it's a real problem.
Because if you have a grant
that has $10,000 of resources,
and you mistakenly
spend $100,000,
well that grant is not going
to pay the extra $90,000
that you spent.
We have to pull that
from some other place.
And we can't pull it
from another grant,
so we have to pull it from
our administrative funds
that we use to run the business.
Now, when we're using
the Public Cloud,
there are some things that we're
particularly concerned about.
We have a lot of issues
that can come up that can
affect the way you spend money.
So for example, as
Matt alluded to,
you can have developers who
are spending up instances,
and they just
leave them running.
And a month later,
you look at your bill,
and you're like, why did I spend
tens of thousands of dollars?
And it's an oopsie situation.
We also use a lot of storage.
Storage is probably 60%
or 70% of our overall cost
of using the Cloud.
So when we make a choice
to put a bunch of storage
into a global bucket, instead
of maybe a Nearline or Coldline
bucket if that's the
way we intend to use it,
that can drastically
change the cost.
And so we want to
be able to keep
an eye on that kind of
stuff and really track it,
so we make good decisions.
We also periodically
have problems
where people know
that they don't
have enough resources
to do the work that they
want to do and do it anyway.
So they come, and they
ask for forgiveness
about this overspend issue.
And we're still having to take
the money from somewhere else
in order to pay for that.
So that's a real big issue.
Something that can
happen is periodically
you will have a
developer make a mistake,
like committing one of their
service accounts JSON keys
to a public GitHub repo.
This is a great
experiment if you
want to see how quickly
cryptominers can find your key,
get into your project, and
spend up lots of instances.
And so many of you
who use the Cloud
may have run into
situations like that.
And so monitoring your
cost is very important,
because that's even worse than
the developer, who spun up a VM
and forgot to shut it down,
because they're literally
going to use all of
the Quota that you have
to try to make as much
crypto as possible
over the smallest
period of time.
And a lot of these
issues, when you're
thinking about moving
a large institution
from your on-prem
environment into the Cloud,
they can create a real
obstacle to being successful.
Because all these people who are
responsible for these grants,
if they have a very controlled
and understood way of managing
their resources in the
on-prem legacy environment,
and they don't have
that in the Cloud,
then that creates a real
fear and uncertainty
about moving to the Cloud.
I know when I run jobs in
our on-prem environment
exactly how much
it's going to cost.
If I go do it in the Cloud,
and I make some mistake,
am I going to spend
all the Broad's money?
That's a big concern.
And that has a lot of people
second guessing the move
to the Cloud.
And so we want to solve that.
So most of the talks that
I give as Cloud architect
at the Broad Institute
have to do with scale.
And so I want to talk about what
I mean when I talk about scale
in our GCP environment.
So many of you--
if you use G Suite, you might
have one G Suite domain.
If you use GCP, you might
have one billing account.
Maybe you have dozens of
projects, potentially.
But we're another order
of magnitude here.
So for example, we have seven
individual G Suite domains,
two of which are
production domains.
And part of the reason for
that is we have a Cloud service
called Fire Cloud, which
is hosted on Google.
And it provides facilities for
researchers around the world
to do genomic analysis.
And the team that manages that
system, part of the application
uses root credentials
in the G Suite domain
to create groups
and create users.
And so we don't want to give out
the credentials for the Broad
Institute's domain
to the team that's
building the software package.
So they have their own
domain for Fire Cloud.
And then we have a bunch of
test domains and quality and QA
and other things that we use
different G Suite domains for.
Across these seven domains,
primarily in our main domain--
BroadInstitute.org-- we
have over 5,000 users.
And this is interesting
because we only
have around 1,400 employees.
So it turns out that we're a
very collaborative and open
institute.
And there are
thousands of people
from our sister institutions
around Cambridge
and the Harvard teaching
hospitals and such,
where they also have
identities in our environment.
And they can log
in to our G Suite.
They can even log
into our clusters.
They can use the
Cloud and so forth.
So it's a very, very
large environment
as far as the number of users.
And it's also very spread
out, because they're not
all within our buildings.
We have 2,500 groups, which is
about one group for every two
users.
And we are set up
in a way that users
can create their own groups.
So there's quite a few of them.
And we use those to manage
Google Doc permissions
to manage access to
GCP projects, Google
sites, any number of
things, in addition
to mailing lists-- which
many of you may use them for.
Now, four of those
G Suite domains
have a corresponding
GCP org that's in use.
There's one for the
Broad Institute, which
our users, when they create
projects-- as you mentioned,
users can create
projects and spend up
resources-- they create their
projects in the Broad Institute
domain.
But Fire Cloud actually
creates projects
as part of its process.
When a new user signs
up for Fire Cloud
and creates workspaces and
starts doing genomic analysis,
there are projects that are
created in the background
by service accounts that
are used by that system.
And those are created in
GCP organizations that
are specific to that domain.
In order to organize all the
things in these organizations,
we have a lot of
folders, and we can
apply permissions and other
controls at the folder level
and at the subfolder level.
And this turns out to
be dozens and dozens--
approaching 200
folders at this point.
We have over 7,000
projects, which becomes
really challenging to manage.
Even if you just want to get
a list of all your projects
and see the IAM
permissions on each one,
that can be an
involved endeavor.
And maybe there's only around
800 or so in our G Suite--
in our primary Broad
Institute domain.
And the rest of them are all
part of the Fire Cloud system.
This slide here says that
I have 75,000 buckets.
That's actually incorrect.
I learned this week that
we have a test project that
has 280,000 buckets in it.
And it's just most of
my systems that monitor
the projects fail on that one.
And I only learned
that this week.
So that should say that
we have 320,000 buckets.
And in those buckets, we have
over 35 petabytes, nearly 40
petabytes of storage to that.
And that's about half
of what we have overall,
because we have about that
same amount in our legacy
on-prem environment
that we still
are trying to figure out how
exactly to move to the Cloud.
And now we get into
the interesting part
with the billing.
We have one billing account,
which is pretty normal.
And like many of you,
our billing account
is a typical, monthly-invoice
billing account.
But we have a configuration
on our account
that we're set up
like a reseller.
Some of you may work with
resellers to purchase your GCP.
And we're set up like that
because we resell the service
to our internal organizations.
And I'm going to go into this
in a lot more detail shortly.
This slide shows a
bunch of the features
that we use within GCP
that help with managing
everything at scale.
I'm actually not going
to go through this,
because I'm going
to do, pretty much,
a slide for each one of those.
So the billing accounts--
I mentioned the
monthly invoicing.
offline contract.
I highly recommend, if
you have a business,
that you're running on GCP.
Look into paying
for it on an invoice
instead of using
your credit card,
because there are certain things
that can happen with the credit
card.
We've had an issue where
someone used the credit
card to purchase
something online,
and they mistyped the zip code.
And then the credit card
company shut down the card.
And so any other services that
were associated with that card
would have problems.
And so we certainly
don't want that to happen
to our GCP environment.
So the way we use
these subaccounts--
let me talk about
that a little bit.
Each one of these grants, and
each one of our internal cost
structures--
and we call them a cost object.
Some people call them a
cost center or an account.
Each one of those that
wants to use the Cloud
gets a subaccount.
And the reason we
do this is because
at the end of the month-- and
we get our one bill from Google,
which we pay, and
then we charge back
to dozens and dozens of
internal-cost objects,
the subportion of the bill
that they actually spend.
So we were originally
doing this two
or three years ago using
labels, which I'll talk
about briefly in another slide.
But the problem with using
labels for this today
is that even if you
create a project
and put a label on it that
says which cost center
it should be billed to,
the owner of that project
can change that.
Or they can remove the label.
And so if you rely on that, as
a way of carving up your bill,
then when you get
the bill, you go,
what is this huge amount that
doesn't have a cost object?
And who should pay for that?
And so that was
very problematic.
And so two years
ago or so, we moved
to this subaccounts
feature, again,
which is specifically
geared towards resellers.
And I think in the future, there
might be some other models that
are coming that would actually
be more appropriate for us,
maybe around using the
folders for example.
So another thing about these
is that each one of these cost
objects is owned by somebody.
They are, maybe, the
principal investigator
on the grant, the person who
is responsible for the funds.
And they may actually have
more than one cost object
that they manage.
So if any of you manage
billing accounts in Google,
when you manage more
than one billing account,
some of the things are around
budget, some around permissions
can get pretty complicated.
And I'll talk about how we
work through some of that.
But the nice thing about
the bill that we got
is that it has one total
at the bottom, which
is the amount we pay.
And then it has 175
subtotals, which
is the amount we charge all
the internal-cost objects.
And we used to have to calculate
that ourselves, so that is
actually a great benefit for us.
One of the other great features
that we use to manage all this
is the BigQuery and
the JSON or CSV Export.
We use both of these right now.
The BigQuery Export
is the most valuable,
and that is the newest
of these features.
The CSV or JSON Export
is useful, for example--
some of you may use
a third-party service
to help visualize your billing
across your multiple Clouds.
We've used tools
like Cloud Health,
for example, in the past.
And they can easily consume
your billing information
from a bucket with a CSV.
And they were doing
that for years,
because that's how Amazon
delivers its bills for example.
And so now, some
of the companies
are starting to be able to use
the BigQuery Export for that
too.
One of the nice things
about the BigQuery Export
is all the data related to your
bill is being piped directly
into BigQuery.
So whatever tools you might
use to deal with BigQuery,
you can use to do that.
So when we want to
visualize this data,
try to understand what's
going on in there,
we have half a dozen
different ways we can do that.
And some of these I'm going to
show in my demo a little later.
So for example, in
the billing console,
there is a new feature that
came out this year called
Billing Reports.
And this allows you to see a
graph of all of the activity
and to narrow it down
by SKU, and by product,
and by time period.
And that, for me, actually is
the best and most common way
that I like to look
at the bill today.
Before that existed
though, we used
a lot of different
methods of looking
at the data in BigQuery.
So for example, we
used Cloud Datalab,
which is like a
IPython, Jupyter,
Notebooks that Google offers.
You can write reports and
display graphs and so forth,
about your billing data.
That was very useful for
us to determine things
like how much data
we have, because you
can't DU all your buckets
when you have 380,000 of them
or whatever.
So it's sometimes
easier to actually
look at the billing data
to calculate how much data
you have.
DataStudio is also an
amazing tool for this.
This is relatively
recent addition as well,
but I absolutely love this.
If you're familiar
with Google Sheets
and making a chart
in Google Sheets,
the user experience of doing
data analysis in DataStudio
is very similar to that.
It's quite easy, and it's a
free service offered by Google.
And then at the Broad, we're
also a big Tableau shop.
We have a lot of
investment in Tableau
and a lot of
expertise in Tableau.
So we've built some
very complicated
and in-depth reports
to understand our GCP
data using Tableau as well.
Another useful feature
is custom IAM roles.
We have one, and very
important, customer
IAM role that we use right now.
There's a few others
that we have developed,
but this is probably
the most useful.
We have an individual in
the procurement department
who is the person that creates
new Google billing accounts.
And people are not allowed
to create billing accounts
except for Stewart.
He has that access.
And so basically the
way the process works
is a user will say they would
like to begin using the Cloud.
They will specify which cost
object they would like to use.
And they will specify
some initial budgets,
like I want to spend
$100 a month or less.
And then Stuart
will go, and he'll
create the billing account.
And he'll give them access
to the billing account.
And he'll create
that initial budget,
and then he'll share
it with them, so
that they can begin using it.
So in order to grant him access
to all of the billing accounts,
we moved all of the
billing accounts
into our GCP
organization, and then we
apply this permission
at the org level.
And so Stuart inherits
this customer mission
at the org level for
all of our resources.
And so what these
three permissions do--
we give him billing account
creator, which I think
is pretty obvious.
It allows him to create
new billing accounts,
and he's the only
one that can do that.
We also give him billing
account administrator,
so that means he can change
the names of the billing
accounts if necessary.
He can add or remove
administrative users
on the account.
And the Project Billing
Admin permission
is also very
important, because it
means he can move any project
in the organization from one
billing account to another,
which you can't do unless you
have both access to the project
and access to the billing
account.
So I mentioned the org
and folders a little bit.
We do have two
production organizations,
one for Fire Cloud and
one for Broad Institute.
And then we have a
few test organizations
that we use as well.
The way we've organized
our folder structure
is not consistent, but we
use different mechanisms
depending on the needs
in a given situation.
So for example, the
first thing that we
do for all of our
billing accounts
is we create a corresponding
folder in the organization
to map to that billing account.
This does a few things for us.
First of all, I'm
anticipating a future
where I might be able to
actually apply the billing
account to the projects
using the folder.
That's not a thing yet.
But in a perfect
world for us, we
would like to be able to
organize projects into folders,
and then have everything
in that folder inherit
the billing from the parent.
That makes it easier
for us to manage.
So that's something
we've been anticipating.
So we've organized
our organization
so it's ready for that.
So even though I think I started
that maybe two years ago,
whenever that feature
exists, we will
be ready to start using it.
MATT LEONARD: It's coming soon.
LUKAS KARLSSON: Oh, yeah.
OK.
So we have a few organizations
that are big GCP users.
The IT organization,
which I'm involved,
is one of those organizations.
And so we have hundreds
of projects amongst us.
And it's become useful to
have folders and subfolders.
So for example, I have a
folder for the IT department,
and then I have subfolders
for the teams within there.
And the managers of
each of those teams
have the right access
on the folders,
so they can put
things in the folder.
And they can have permission
over all their stuff.
One of the other
benefits, actually,
of the billing folders
that I didn't mention
is that there's an
interesting thing.
If you are a billing
administrator,
and you own a billing
account because you're
responsible for the
money, you may not really
be the person who actually
does anything in GCP.
So you may delegate
another person
on your team to have
billing-account user
permission.
And that allows that person
to create as many projects
as they want on your
billing account.
It's analogous to giving someone
a credit card on your account
and letting them do
whatever they want with it.
The unfortunate
thing about that is
if that person, who makes
that project on your billing
account, does not give
you access to the project,
you have literally no idea what
your money is being spent on.
So we have people contacting
IT being like, what
is all the money in here?
And I'm like, I don't know.
One of your people made that.
Can you talk to them?
And so it turns out
it's much easier
if we give the billing-account
administrator, at least,
viewer-level access
on the folder.
And if all the projects that
are associated with that billing
account are somewhere
beneath that folder,
then magically the
billing-account administrator
also has access
to see everything
that their people are
creating, which is a huge win.
And then there's some
situations where you might
use folders for other purposes.
For example, if I have one very
sensitive project that I only
want a few people to access, and
all the rest of the projects I
want a larger number
of people to access,
I might, at the top
level, have those as two
separate, top-level folders.
And that way, I can have
a very restrictive folder
that only inherits a limited
amount of permissions.
And I maybe apply no
permissions at the top level
in that situation.
That way, your
sensitive projects
can go in that sensitive,
high-level folder.
And the other things
can go elsewhere.
So we use that in a few places.
Quotas I won't talk about too
much, for a couple of reasons.
One is, if your quotas
are high enough,
then they're not really
guardrails to protect you.
So for example, if you
have a project where,
next week, you're going to need
to run a job that uses 50,000
VMs, and you raise your quota
to 50,000 VMs, then now,
that's what your
quota is set to.
So that's not going
to prevent you
from spending a lot of money.
If you leave those 50,000 VMs
running, then definitely--
you're certainly going to
spend a lot of money on that.
And so when you run at the scale
that we do, and your quotas
have to be as high
as ours are, they
turn out not to
be as protective.
And so again, this is
something that I would
like to deal with differently.
And so I've been
envisioning the idea
of being able to control
this at those folder levels,
as I mentioned.
So maybe if I had,
at the folder level,
the ability to control which
quota assigned to which things,
that would be more
useful for us.
And so again, we're
hoping for a future
where that is a truth thing.
You don't need to say anything.
[LAUGHTER]
So I think this
is my last slide.
The budgets and
notifications are probably
why I'm here to talk
with you all today.
So we have dozens and
dozens of budgets.
Each one of the billing accounts
has one or more budgets on it.
If you've used this feature,
if you used billing accounts
and budgets, then up
until earlier this year,
the only way you would get
notified about these things
was via email.
And if you're like
me, and you happen
to be a billing administrator
on a 175 billing accounts,
then the number of
notifications you
get from Google about a budget
that is over a threshold
is a lot.
It's multiple times a day.
And I certainly can't react to
all of those in a sensible way.
So mostly I ignore them,
which is a problem.
So the addition of
Pub/Sub notifications
basically changes all this.
And this has been
extremely exciting for me,
because I've been working
with Google on this billing
stuff for a few years.
And I've come up with ways
to read all the emails
and try to automatically
react to the emails.
But that is not
a scalable model,
so this Pub/Sub thing
is really great.
And I'm actually-- attempt
to show a demo of this.
And we'll see if it
actually does what I want.
But the purpose here
would be that you
can send these notifications
to a Cloud Function,
and then you can have that
Cloud Function wired up
to do things that you want
in certain situations.
So for example, if
there's a budget,
and I know that if that budget
hits a certain threshold
that there's an action I
know why I want to take,
I could wire this up
with Cloud Functions.
And I've attempted
to do that here.
I'm not super confident, but
I'll try to as best I can.
And then the final
thing that I'll mention
is that we've built a bunch
of little custom tools using
Google's APIs, using the IAM
APIs, and the Cloud Resource
Manager, and the Billing
APIs, and others to automate
a lot of the stuff that we do.
So I'm going to try and
show a couple of those.
There's an app that I
built like a week ago,
which is the first
one I'm going to show.
It's very simple.
It just recreates Stuart's
job of creating and managing
all the billing accounts.
And then I'm going to
show this other App Engine
App that I made--
that its whole purpose is to
try and deal with these budget
notifications.
And that's where I'm a
little more skeptical about
whether or not
it's going to work.
Before I show the
demo, I'm going
to talk about the architecture
of this billing-notifications
app.
I have a bunch of logos up here.
I'll see if I can make
sense of this for you.
So on the left-hand
side, you see, in red,
the master-billing account.
That is the Broad's
normal billing account.
We got a bill each
month from that thing.
And underneath that, you see
there's several subaccounts.
So each of those sub accounts
has one or more budgets.
And those budgets
are all wired up
to send their information,
their notifications,
to the same Pub/Sub topic.
So we have one Pub/Sub
topic that is receiving
a barrage of notifications.
They come in maybe a
couple times an hour
for every single budget.
So where you normally
get notified via email,
let's say once a
week or something--
I don't know exactly
the frequency--
these are coming in all
the time, every hour.
And so whether or not you've
hit one of the thresholds,
you know the state of each of
your budgets at any given time.
So those all feed
into Cloud Pub/Sub,
and then there's this
function at the bottom there
that consumes all of the
input from that Cloud Pub/Sub.
And it does some stuff, like it
stores the budget information
and data-store database.
So I can look at any given time
and see the status of all 175
budgets without having to click
through 175 different billing
accounts.
It logs in in Cloud Logging,
so I know it happened.
And then it uses a look-up
tool to try and figure out
if it should take an action.
And if it determines that
it should take an action,
then it kicks off one
of these other Cloud
Functions on the right there.
I have one called
Disabled Billing,
one called Stop
Compute Instances,
and one called Notify Slack.
And each of those
does, basically,
what it says it does.
And there's a couple of
other icons on there.
I use BigQuery
because I like to look
at how much spam we've had
up to this point in the year.
That's a helpful,
little thing to look at.
When you're looking at
the budget and the spend,
that's useful.
And then the Cloud
Resource Manager
because one of the
things this app does
is it visits each
billing account
to get all of the
IAM permissions
and see who the users
are associated with that.
Again, that is an operation
that takes a while.
And so I chache that data,
so I have easy ability
to report on who is associated
with all of our billing
accounts.
And on the App Engine
app, users can log on,
and it uses the identity
of our proxy to make sure
that only Broad users log in.
And the next thing is, since I
know which users are associated
with which billing accounts, I
can show them only the billing
accounts that relate to them.
And first, let me wake
up my computer here--
type in my password.
Then we are going to
switch to the demo.
Great.
OK.
So this app here is a
simple, little app that--
I just built it last week, so
it only does Google right now.
But it'll do other things soon.
It has a list of--
I guess there's 188
billing accounts now.
So my slide is out
of date already.
Some of them are disabled.
Billing accounts
don't have a ton
of things like labels
or other stuff,
so we have to use the actual
name of the billing account.
So when I take a billing account
that I'm not using anymore
and stop using it, I changed
the name to disabled.
So this is really useful.
You have a list of all the
billing accounts, which
cost object it's linked to.
You can tell if
it's open or closed.
And you can jump to the console
for that particular billing
account.
And I have one that I
actually made specifically
for this demo, which is going
to come into play in a moment.
Another thing this
app can do is it has
a list of all of our invoices.
I'm not showing anything useful
here, because this actually
doesn't do anything yet.
But the premise of this
app is that because it
knows which billing accounts
are associated with which
cost objects, and
because Stuart can
use it to create new
billing accounts,
the idea is it will
also be used to generate
the internal charges.
And we use SAP.
So at some point, this will
calculate the bill each month
and split it across
multiple things,
and generate the totals.
We've had a bunch of
users recently who
they have a more complicated
spending situation.
So instead of using one-cost
object for their project,
and all the money charges
to that one cost object,
they need to split the funds
across many different cost
objects, which has
become complicated.
So part of what this system
does is allow for that.
So for example, this
group here, every month,
they split whatever spend they
had across 13 different cost
objects.
And so this is not something
that Google supports currently.
And the way we're
using these billing
accounts-- so we have to create
a whole structure for this.
And there's a few other
useful tools here.
Like, because we know
all the cost objects
and what's affiliated with
them, we can do some checking
and see which billing accounts
don't have a cost object.
Or apparently all these
billing accounts--
the cost object has expired.
That's really fun for us,
because we get the bill.
We process the
bill, and then we go
to charge all the internal
cost objects back.
And then it turns out 10
or 12 of them are over,
and we have to figure out
what the new cost object is.
So this is finally a way
that Stuart, in one place,
can see all of that information
and can react to it.
And again, this
doesn't do much today.
But when Stuart wants to
create a new billing account,
he can just click there.
He can create one that's
directly associated
with a specific cost object.
Or he can create one
that has a split.
So now, the other
thing I want to show
is this thing that does
all of the notifications.
So as a user at the Broad,
if I were to log in to this,
I would just see my
own billing account.
So this demo account only
has one billing account.
And that only has two budgets.
But if I log in
as myself, then I
have several billing
accounts and a bunch
of different budgets.
And I can see them all in one
place, which is really useful.
Now, there's a thing
on here that I kind of
created-- that most
of this is just
printing out the data that
comes from those budget
notifications.
But this projection column
is something that I added in.
Typically, if any of you
use Google billing accounts,
and you get these
alerts, you have
to know what the data is
to know whether you care.
So if I get an alert that says,
I'm over 50% on my budget,
if I look at my watch,
and I see that today
is the second of the month,
well, that's a huge problem.
But if today is the 24th,
then I do not care at all,
and I don't even need
that notification.
So what I've done is
I've tried to predict,
in a lazy way, how much
the budget is going
to be at the end
of the month, which
is what you really care about.
And so if you're at 50%
and today is the 24th,
then you're really not
going to hit anything,
so it's nothing to worry about.
But if it's like the
second day of the month,
and you're already at 50%,
then it's a big problem.
And so that graph
shows how likely
you are to go over
your budget at the end.
Now, I'm going to skip
through some of this,
because the most
important thing here
is to show the notifications.
So I'm going to show you
the key features that
have to do with that.
So in addition to a list of all
the billing accounts in here,
which is very important
and apparently taking
its sweet time to load,
I have a list of actions
that I have invented.
And so there's four right now.
Only three of them work.
But it's the same things
Matt mentioned earlier.
I can notify Slack
instead of email.
I can stop the
compute instances,
which is a big hammer, but
not as big as the last one
which is to turn off
billing entirely.
And then I have these
thresholds that I
can define in here to say, well,
when this particular budget
hits this particular
limit, I want
to take this specific action.
And this is very simple.
I only have one budget
in here, and it only
has the three actions to find.
But I should be able to demo
this, if things go well here.
So because this
all uses Pub/Sub,
I'm not actually going to spend
the next 30 minutes waiting
for my account to
hit the budget,
and then to notify Pub/Sub.
I can just send a Pub/Sub
message to fake that.
So I'm going to do that here.
So let's say that this
particular budget has
hit 80%, which currently
that's the only attribute I'm
triggering on-- is which
threshold you have exceeded.
I could also trigger off of
the cost amount, for example.
But it's not doing that today.
OK.
So I posted this
new Pub/Sub message.
Let's see what happened.
Maybe it'll take a moment?
MATT LEONARD: Next to Wi-Fi.
LUKAS KARLSSON: Yeah.
Great.
Nothing happened.
Let's try this again.
Am I in the correct project?
No, I am not.
That's the problem.
Here we go.
OK.
I'm searching for this string.
Let's see what it says.
Still nothing.
Let's just look.
OK.
Well, my logging is not telling
me what I wanted to see.
But I did just get a Slack
notification at 3:59 PM,
saying that this budget,
for this billing account,
has exceeded the 0.8 threshold.
And that that billing has
these three projects associated
with it.
And I can click here to
link to the billing account.
So that worked.
That's great.
I'm going to try one more,
which may have the same behavior
as the last one.
But let's see what happens if
I hit the 90% threshold here.
We get another message.
We'll see if the logs
show anything this time.
Oh.
I'm in the wrong thing.
Here we go.
Thank you.
OK.
So it looks like
we got a message.
There was a notification
for this budget,
and it looks like it's calling
a Cloud Function called
Stop Compute Instances.
It looks like it
stopped some instances.
So wow.
Let's see if that
really happened.
We have Compute
Window open here.
And we want to be
in the demo account.
And it looks like those
two instances are stopping.
Well, that's exciting.
Let's look at the
billing icon here.
So the billing account still has
these three projects associated
with it, but apparently, these
two instances, as well as
there's an instance in each
of the other two projects--
they're all stopping right now.
And then the end of my demo
will be when I send the 1.0,
and let's see what happens.
Come on.
There we go.
Looks like we got
a notification.
It looks like we
exceeded 100% of $200.
And now, we're hitting the
Disable Billing function,
and then we have successfully
disabled billing.
And when we go back to
this billing account,
and we see which projects
are associated with it,
there aren't any.
So that worked-- was amazing.
[APPLAUSE]
OK.
We can switch back
to the slides now.
Great.
MATT LEONARD: You're back.
LUKAS KARLSSON: That was what
I just did, so announce you.
MATT LEONARD: All right.
We've left a ton of time for
questions, unfortunately.
I wanted to give
a quick shout out
to some of the other sessions
on billing Lucas alluded to--
some of the other functions
that are available for billing.
So if you missed
it this morning,
there's managing costs and GCP.
Coming up on Wednesday, we
have diving into billing data
with BigQuery and DataStudio.
So obviously, we publish
detail-billing data
into BigQuery.
And more detail-billing
data is coming
over the next
couple of quarters,
so you can do new and
interesting things.
You can then build DataStudio
templates on top of that.
As Lucas alluded to, I'm
now talking really fast,
because we're
almost out of time.
But we have a billing template
that allow you to dashboard,
essentially, standardize
views within that DataStudio
template.
Just copy, pointed at your
data set, and off you go.
Everyone can become a
DataStudio expert overnight.
And lastly, monitoring and
forecasting your costs.
So it's like [? AR ?] reporting.
We have a showcase
downstairs, if you guys
want to play around with some of
the financial governance tools
that we talked about.
And there's a few
concepts that they're
running through down there.
Lastly, I just
want to reiterate--
there is no one-size-fits-all.
As Lukas demonstrated
in his demo,
you might have different
actions that you
want to enforce at
different budget thresholds
and for different environments.
And so you need to
consider that as you
think about your
financial-governance strategy.
Really, really
quickly-- because I
want to be respectful
of time-- does anybody
have an urgent question?
Or ultimately, you can come and
chat with us after the session?
No.
OK.
Great.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]